I think the most striking an optimistic
thing in all of this is that thirty one
percent of those businesses we surveyed
have said they've really woken up to
exporting and are trying to increase how
much they export that's significant
because of course the UK hasn't had a
great track record over time and getting
more companies out there into market and
indeed driving up the value of what we
export if more companies are engaged
excited and interested as a result of
the brexit discussion that's good news
for our exporting future what's really
interesting though is that the vast
majority of companies that you've
surveyed nearly two-thirds say that the
referendums had absolutely no impact
whatsoever on their export plans well
what's what's interesting here is that
these are companies that by and large
are already exporting they're already in
the game and they're the sorts of
companies who probably have weathered
many different storms with a political
economic or financial in the past so
they know that keeping their export
markets is hugely important to them and
of course they're going to continue and
intensify their strategies in the post
referendum era businesses by and large
are simply carrying on I'd sort of split
it this way about a quarter of our firms
are saying to us I'm directly affected
and I need to look at what mitigations I
need to put in place what scenario
planning I need to do etc the other
three quarters say I know I'll be
affected but it's indirect I've got my
head down I'm doing business I'll
respond to conditions as they arise and
I'm just being pragmatic and I hope that
that sort of pragmatic attitude can
continue over time because those
businesses that are looking at the
fundamentals and their own firms and
their own business plans rather than
listening to so much of the noise we
have around us right now do you think
that will change once article 50s
actually triggered well there are a
number of points across the next couple
of years which could cause businesses to
reassess their strategies to look at
doing things a little bit differently
but that pragmatism I see it from
Cornwall to Inverness I see it from
Northern Ireland to Norfolk and it's
deeply deeply ingrained amongst many
phones they say we've weathered change
before we will do it again this may be a
bigger change than many of the ones
we've seen in the past but we're going
to keep on traded do you see much
appetite to go into new territories away
from Europe well that there is
significant appetite and you know
business
to see not America for example is
another market where they're looking at
intensifying the amount of resource they
put into selling into that particular
market mr. Trump's decision to ban
migrants from certain countries the
United States at the moment potentially
that is chucking sand in the wheels of
free trade we are starting to hear some
concerns from businesses about the
uncertainty generated by some of these
migration changes in this case it's the
US but if it happened in other markets
around the world I think there would
also be concerned from British
businesses worried about other people
they've got out in market at the moment
or people that need to visit a market
that may see that that becomes more
difficult in future so I think it's
incumbent on our government trying to
help our businesses continue to trade
and continue to be able to get their
people around the world because so much
of export is indeed a face to face
business it's a contact sport and being
able to get into market is going to be
important so do you worry that there
could be tit-for-tat reprisals from some
of the countries that Trump there's not
barred its Nationals from the US i'm not
sure but one thing that i know would be
very bad for business in the UK and
indeed in other outward-looking markets
like our own would be a protectionist
migration measures across the board
businesses benefit hugely from being
able to go out to visit their clients
and suppliers wherever they may be and
if that becomes harder we may see the
amount of trade that happens decrease I
don't think anyone wants to see that
they've been calls for mr. Trump to no
longer have a state visit open to him
post these changes as he's made on
immigration where would you stand on
that well I mean I think businesses are
inherently a pragmatic bunch but they
would want to see is the political
leaders of both the US and the UK
looking at ways to improve trade and
improve ties between the two countries I
don't think they would take a view
necessarily on the politics of it but
I'm sure that they would want their
concerns to be strongly worded to any
visitor that may come in this way